the Texas side should have a straight
leg because they're going full out to
get me
[Applause]
my foot faces
my partner
if I have a bent leg ah
I can ski to a straight leg
if I come here ah with a straight leg
it's very different oh it's very
difficult to get any damage you might
not take the wrist off but
this would mean if he saw my movement
he'd just turn and cut me so I
bend my leg
then you can go to straight
we're not going to do the ski I'm just
telling you
bye
[Applause]
there's two ways you can do it this foot
what we'll do this morning and you can
do the other foot
where you bring this one over
it's a little more difficult
so we'll step off with the left
and my partner here is doing the first
sabari
the first suburb he's trying he should
relax after the cut
I also relax after cat
watch
the shoulders everything is settling
your zanshin you're checking yourself
out how you felt what went wrong if
everything was okay
and then it's changed
senkai kotai three times
there is repetition you know it's just a
process of repetition
you know I could tell you all the
answers under the under the Sun but you
know repetition training is the only way
constant training continuous training
but good teachers
with Bad Teachers you'll you'll do like
ideas you'll uh you'll spend many years
going uphill when you should have been
going
a long way that gets you distance
if we don't know what's up there yet but
you know that's that just gets you so
you know you can think you're going the
right way by training hard if you've got
not good teachers
then it's it's even harder all right so
I have good correct form
[Applause]
relax
when I was younger we used to just go
100 miles an hour
that there was some goodness in it I
don't know
okay same partner now you keep the same
partner in rap weapons training meters
or if you're like me 12 inches off your
shoulder
I pick up half cut
I don't rest on my head I step back I
adjust the front foot
so it faces him
he picks up he cuts my other shoulder
he does all this in a rational Pace um
he doesn't just
lose himself in the movement
a good firm strike
and I don't cut his Ken I cut straight
through him that's
[Music]
okay but we're only gonna have enough
room for two
then I go come back no
my foot as the attacker faces him so
here's a little secret
if you was to step over there this would
happen
but look where my foot's gone ah and now
it's twisted
this is a typical Aikido posture
but my knees bent my knee feels under a
little pressure
it's not so bad it's looking down there
the pressure's not so much
there's the uh there's the answer as I'm
going through the air I turn my hip
and now
I'm dead online with my whole body
I turn my hip and place it down ah
okay this would mean
in a real situation I'd really put
pressure on him because I'm On Target
every time
just jumping out the way then turning to
cut makes you always an ending you'll
never be a chief but getting this I
you're lining up from head to toe hey
exactly where you need it
it would seem odd to go
like this well it would to me
it means that if I transferred my weight
and relaxed my body would automatically
swing round you should try it sometime
you'll find when you've got relaxed hips
and it just so happens I've ended up in
Aikido posture
so that means there's no tension on my
body
but this way
relax
it's like a spring I was taught this by
a 23 year old American lady called Kayla
fader
and she's been training I could do since
since she was this high and she's a
monster now
because she's so good because she's
followed the the right path
and she said if you do that
we've been the part one day and she says
you do that and stand out and relax I
said yeah nothing happened she said
that's because you're not relaxed
let's try it again so I went oh yeah
that just come around a little piece
and she said oh well just keep trying it
and so now
you know so many years on I'm starting
to understand it I was taught that by a
23 year old when I was in my 30s
middle 30s so it proves that everybody
can teach you something if they've got a
good point to teach you
a lot of you keep talking to each other
you don't even know the techniques so
you know you're teaching somebody at the
bad habit that you've already got
because I'll come up to you and say no
no that's wrong do that I'll thank you
Scentsy and then you'll say I know you
want to change this a bit and that
he's the only person that knows and he
is not here to tell us so the thing to
do is rightly or wrongly is you don't
know
you say just a minute
and you just have a look around a moment
a high enough grade and you watch them a
couple of times and you go okay
well that's about all you really you'd
need to speak
so in an hour and a half training
uh perhaps 10 yes or no's or just a
month and then it's then it's good
training you get a benefit from inside
you don't get a benefit through talking
show you once more
okay check his foot out and then you can
tell him off afterwards Kevin
this is very new so your scents he
doesn't even know this yet
it's about four weeks old
[Applause]
both our feet must end up facing
a person good
and then three would do it twice and
then we'll go back
please try this